♪♪
>> MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES,
GENTLEMEN AND LADIES --
(LAUGHTER)
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE WHICH HAS COME TO OUR
ATTENTION, THE CONFEDERATE FLAG.
NOW, GENTLEMEN, I KNOW IT'S A
BIT DIFFICULT, DUE WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT -- BUT WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT WHEN WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT THE ACTUAL TAKING OF IT
DOWN.
>> I HAVE NOTES HERE AND WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY TALK ABOUT
TALKING ABOUT TAKING DOWN THE
FLAG.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT WE NEED TO DISCUSS TODAY
IS WHEN IS A BETTER TIME FOR US
TO HAVE SAID DISCUSSION.
>> A FINE SUGGESTION.
GUYS, GUYS, HOW ABOUT WE'RE
ALL HERE RIGHT NOW.
WHY DON'T WE JUST TALK ABOUT IT
NOW?
WE'RE ALL HERE.
>> WELL, YOU ARE NOT USED TO OUR
SOUTHERN WAYS.
THERE IS A TRADITION OF
DISCUSSING HOW WE DEAL WITH OUR
TRADITIONS.
>> YES.
MAY I SUGGEST WE TAKE A
RECESS TO PONDER THESE THOUGHTS?
>> THAT IS A FINE SUGGESTION!
BUT THE MEETING JUST STARTED,
GUYS!
♪♪
>> Larry: WELCOME BACK,
GENTLEMEN. I APOLOGIZE FOR HOW
HASTY THIS HAS BEEN
SHALL WE GET BACK TO THE
BUSINESS AT HAND?
>> I HAVE A DATE WE CIRCLED IN
MY CALENDAR.
>> WHAT IS YOUR DATE, SIR?
AUGUST 14th.
I'M AFRAID, GENTLEMEN, I HAVE
A BARBECUE THAT DAY.
>> OH, WELL...
YEAH, YOU GOT TO RESPECT A MAN'S
BARBECUE.
BARBECUE SEASON IS VERY TRICKY.
DOES MARCH WORK FOR YOU ALL?
>> (BLEEP)!
JUST GIVE ME THE KEY AND I'LL
TAKE THE FLAG DOWN!
>> YOU, SIR, ARE NO GENTLEMAN.
SIR, IF I MAY, LET'S TAKE A
RECESS TO THINK ABOUT WHEN WE
SHOULD TALK ABOUT THE TALKING
ABOUT YOUR GENTLEMANLINESS.
(BLEEP) SOUTH CAROLINA.